do you believe in coincidences because
an amazing coincidence happened
yesterday you see yesterday Sam bankman
freed who's the scam artist behind the
FTX crypto exchange collapse he was
arrested in the Bahamas
just one day before he was scheduled to
testify before the house Financial
Services committee now initially SBF as
he is called had said that he did not
want to testify
and Maxine Waters the head of the house
committee she didn't seem especially to
mind that he refused to testify she
didn't push back all that much did not
issue a subpoena nothing like that which
makes sense since SBF was the second
largest donor to the Democrat Party this
past cycle and the collapse of his scam
looks pretty terrible for Democrats in
the house and everywhere else but he was
still scheduled to appear which was
going to be a lose-lose situation for
the Democrats since whether he showed up
or not the Democrats are going to look
either corrupt or weak or both and then
then what do you know
the guy gets arrested just 24 hours
before the appearance and so he can't
show up I can't I can't help but notice
also that Maxine Waters doesn't seem all
that broken up about it she said he was
he was planning to appear before the
committee tomorrow
but then he was arrested although Mr
bankman freed must be held accountable
the American public deserves to hear
directly from Mr bankman freed about the
actions that have harmed over one
million people and wiped out the
hard-earned life savings of so many the
public has been eagerly waiting to get
those answers under oath before Congress
the timing of this arrest denies this
public opportunity while I am
disappointed that we will not be able to
hear from Mr bankman free tomorrow we
remain committed to getting to the
bottom of what happened and this
committee looks forward to beginning our
investigation by hearing from some other
guy tomorrow ah darn dratz we really
wanted to hear from our second largest
donor about the huge scam that he was
perpetrating that allowed him to fund
all of our campaigns last cycle but darn
it dagnabbit it just didn't work out the
largest financial scam potentially in
history perpetrated by the Democrats
second largest donor and now we're
unlikely ever to hear much of anything
about it what are the chances
about as believable as sbf's balance
sheet I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Gary mcderp
who says this is about Sam Brinton he's
the the energy guy that the nuclear
waste guy in the bite Administration
with the bald head and the red lipstick
and the stilettos and the guys on the
leash and so you're telling me that a
guy with a shaved head and mustache that
wears lipstick women's dresses and high
heels and dresses up in bondage gear and
walks other dudes around on a leash like
dogs was exhibiting signs of abnormal
behavior when he was stealing luggage at
the airport I don't believe it
I know it just doesn't add up
just doesn't make sense kind of like the
arrest of Sam bankman freed it's just ah
what are the odds
what are the odds
it's always the ones you most expect
it's always it's always the things and
the people that you most expect okay now
when I expect to have a good meal and
feel very satisfied and get a lot of
iron pumping through my blood I turn to
good ranchers right now head on over to
goodranters.com use code Knowles a hard
year on the economy means that essential
practical gifts will be in high demand
give the most essential gift of all
America's best meat and seafood from
good Ranchers with discounts on orders
of five boxes or more you can save on
gifts for the whole family when you give
a box of good ranchers you are giving
them a true Steakhouse experience with
100 American USDA prime and upper Choice
cuts of beef Chicken and Seafood other
meat delivery companies and even your
local grocery stores import lower
Quality Meat from overseas do not give
your friends and family less than
America's best this year not sure what
to order good ranchers now offers gift
cards so you can let your friends and
family members choose for themselves or
give the gift of a subscription and
inflation proof someone's meat budget go
to goodranchers.com use code Knowles
Canada wlas a check out to get 35 off
your gift that is goodranchers.com code
Knowles for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered speaking of
corrupt Democrats getting their
comeuppance
we turn away from Washington we turn
toward Silicon Valley San Francisco Elon
Musk
is not only kicking a ton of Twitter
employees out and encouraging them to
quit or firing them out right he's now
also selling all their stuff so Elon
Musk is auctioning off
all the really nice amenities that the
Twitter employees had at their office
which they didn't even use because they
didn't show up to the office but really
high-end espresso machines lounge chairs
all these sorts of other employee toys
what oh it's a la marzoco espresso
machine that sounds nice road is all
rotisserie ovens what were they doing I
get they were just sort of cooking their
own chickens maybe at lunch commercial
blenders Grinders refrigerators grills
griddles fryers braising pans and pizza
ovens
that's what the Twitter employees got to
do after after their long shifts
censoring you and kicking duly elected
Republicans off of the platform and
covering up for the Democrats and
Shilling for Joe Biden and then they
would they needed a break they were so
exhausted so they would have to kick
back with their nice rotisserie chicken
in their lounge chair sipping their
lovely espresso well not anymore because
one Elon Musk has fired a lot of those
employees and two he's selling all of
their stuff through Heritage Global
Partners
he's also selling a bunch of their
office gear computer receipts that sort
of thing so if you want a piece of
Twitter
you can you can go get that he's also
selling symbols of Twitter so there's a
giant statue of the Twitter logo there
is a sculpture of the at sign that that
denotes a person's Twitter handle he's
selling that too he's solving or he's
selling rather to novelty stationary
bikes that were used to charge
Electronics he's he's selling a lot of
it why is he doing that
in part I'm sure he's doing it for the
money it's a lot of stuff and they don't
need it anymore so they can sell it but
it's not really about the money
all of that is going to be a rounding
error on Twitter's budget
Elon Musk is selling all the fun
employee toys to assert his dominance
over the company and to that I say my
hat is off to you sir great job I
applaud it I think it's really really
smart and conservatives
ought to learn from this
Elon Musk engaged in a very hostile
takeover of this company it was about as
hostile as a takeover can possibly be
and he got a lot of pushback from the
employees so even after the sale went
through there were a lot of people
saying well you're not going to be able
to do this Elon we're gonna we're gonna
stand up to you we're gonna stop this
awful far right wing takeover even
though Elon Musk is Center left
at most and Elon said nope not the case
you're fired you're fired you're fired
he engaged in all these kinds of little
tricks he would send out emails and then
see who would leak the emails and then
he had little markers on the emails to
find out who leaked fire those people he
encouraged a bunch of people to leave
he's just he's actually making life much
more difficult for the Twitter employees
to strategic effect because it separates
the wheat from the chaff it boots out a
lot of the libs he's he is intentionally
antagonizing his employees to get them
to leave
because the ones who are antagonized by
his Antics are not the kind of employees
that he wants this is what Republicans
should do when we come into political
power we don't do it unfortunately and
it's harder because there are more rules
around government but when we come in
and we appoint people to the various
agencies and departments don't forget
there are some 2 million employees in
the permanent government in the
bureaucracy and the associated
Departments of the government we need to
come in and we need to we need to sell
out sell the microwaves we need to sell
the lounge chairs we need to make life
difficult we need to increase working
hours we need to make it harder to
jump off the clock and dawdle and do all
the sorts of things that a lot of these
people do
we need to make it a fairly hostile work
environment because the people who run
the show over there overwhelmingly are
our political enemies and so if we allow
life to remain Pleasant for them in
their jobs they're just going to
continue to undermine us okay we know we
never seem to have the guts for that
though
we never see learn a lesson elected
Republicans learn a lesson 2024
presidential candidates learn a lesson
potential appointees do the Elon thing
go in scorched Earth tell them their
lives are going to be much much harder
and sell all their toys and salt the
Earth so that nothing will ever grow
there again whether we're talking about
it Twitter or we're talking about in the
various government agencies speaking of
people getting fired
Sam Brinton alluded to in my favorite
comment of the day yesterday which I
just read
has been fired
he has been fired not
after it came to light that he shows up
to bondage fetish events and leads grown
men around on dog leashes and dresses
them up in weird little leather costumes
not after Sam Brinton shows up to White
House events wearing stiletto heels and
lipstick not after Sam Brenton steals a
woman's jewelry allegedly at an airport
and clothing and all all of her
possessions in her suitcase
but after he does that
for a second time
and is caught on camera doing it and
becomes too much of a distraction that
even the Biden White House has to fire
him according to the doe Sam Brinton is
no longer a doe employee but the
department of energy cannot comment
further on Personnel matters
okay good not only has the right been
calling attention to this guy and saying
wait what on Earth you're telling me
this obviously deeply troubled lunatic
is in charge of nuclear waste in the
federal government but even even members
of the lgbtq plus Community have warned
about this guy for a long time
in lgbtq nation not exactly a far-right
publication the headline just came out
is
has Sam brinton's story always been too
good to be true
was Brenton's story contrived or
embellished to manipulate high-profile
leaders and Elevate themselves into oh
that's the
themselves is the singular crazy pronoun
if you don't want to acknowledge that
you're a man or a woman but him himself
is what they mean into the upper
echelons of the lgbtq plus activism and
there he is and what's the story the
story is oh Sam Britain's told a few
stories
but the big one the central part of his
personal narrative his lgbtq journey is
that Sam Brinton was subjected to
conversion therapy
conversion therapy what is it nobody
quite seems to know but if he had the
conversion therapy this was traumatic
and it was awful except his story didn't
quite hold up
he's been telling it since he was at the
treasure Trevor Project the national
Center for lesbian rights now in the
federal government it just doesn't quite
he said that he came out to his parents
at the age of 11 and then his father
started punching him and he went to the
emergency room and then he was sent to
conversion therapy and then they tried
to beat the gay out of him basically but
then his story started to change because
when he was asked about it he said who
was the Doctor Who was the what was the
office what was this
he refused to answer and as lgbtq Nation
even acknowledges
they say this is kind of odd
if such a place existed there's a moral
imperative to rapidly identify the
abusive therapist and contact the
authorities to stop the atrocities
why was Sam Brinton the only of the only
Survivor of conversion therapy I've
encountered since 1998 who refused to
answer such questions
not only had every other Survivor
provided this information willingly but
they were eager to fight back and shut
down their own therapist or ex-gay
Minister and so then Sam starts changing
his story he writes changes the timeline
of when he went to the so-called
conversion there it's just very clear to
conservatives to liberals to lgbtq
activists it's clear to anyone who's
interested in the truth this guy has
made up his whole story he's obviously a
pathological liar he's a thief he's a
deeply troubled deeply confused man
and only after everybody in the country
agrees on that from the most super
straight conservative to the most lgbtq
left-wing activist only then does Joe
Biden say okay only after he's accused
of two felonies this is Joe Biden say
okay maybe we got to take him off the
nuclear nuclear waste in the federal
government doesn't make sense now if you
want to look good
not look kind of crazy and eccentric but
look really really good you got to check
out mizen and Maine right now go to
mizzeninmaine.com use code Knowles
missing and Maine are the inventors of
the performance fabric dress shirt is
there anything worse than being
uncomfortable can you imagine being
uncomfortable while also not looking
your best that would be horrible luckily
missing in Maine has the solution
they've made the most lightweight
breathable and moisture wicking dress
shirt you can buy they're high
performance dress shirts are warm in
Winter and cool in summer think of their
clothing as your secret weapon for any
occasion
I'm confident if you give Ms and Main a
try you will never go back to
Conventional men's clothing again
missing a man's dress shirts are the
best dress shirts I have ever come
across I love this fabric I love the
look
the look is just so clean and smart
machine washable so you don't need to go
to the dry cleaner all the time check
out missing and Mains over 30 000
five-star reviews online look your best
this season with mizzen and Maine right
now
if you go to Mission and main.com use
promo code Knolls you will receive 35
off any regular priced order of 125 or
more that is 35 off when you go to m i z
z e n a n d m a i n.com use promo code
Knowles
it's a big part of Sam brinton's stories
about this thing called conversion
therapy
but what is conversion therapy
some people have in their minds that
it's when you you take gay guys and you
they're little kids even they often say
it's done with little kids and you just
basically attach them to electrodes you
just electrocute them until they stop
being gay or something that obviously is
is not the case that is not practiced
anywhere
that that's that's kind of the image
that the libs wanted to create for Mike
Pence in 2016.
because Mike Pence signed some law that
had some health care provision that
funded some kind of therapy that was
completely misrepresented
to suggest that it was this awful
traumatic conversion therapy
but you know what conversion therapy
actually is
it's when a guy walks into a
psychologist and says hey Doc I'm a
little confused about my sex and my
gender and I'm a man
but maybe I think I'm a woman or I'm a
man but but I'm not really as attracted
to women and a more attracted to men and
I don't want to be I want to be
attracted to women and doc I don't know
what to do I don't know how to help
myself work through these these feelings
and the psychological confusion
if the doc tells that guy
that patient
that he is a man say hey buddy I know
you're going through a lot of confusion
but you are a man and So you you're not
really a woman and it is sort of normal
if you're a man to uh have a
relationship with a woman and then maybe
get married or if that is not amenable
to you maybe to remain chased or
celibate if you're experiencing distress
because let's say your religious views
tell you that you can't indulge same-sex
attractions but you have these
attractions so what are you going to do
I'm going to help you work through this
in a way
that is conducive with
your biological sex or understanding of
what sex means and gender expression the
religious views that you hold the
cultural values that we've had for many
many years if if the doctor says any of
those things
that's evil conversion therapy that's
illegal in half the states in this
country
if on the other hand
the psychologist tells the patient oh
hey buddy you're not really a buddy
you're a chick you're a woman you need
to take a bunch of very powerful drugs
you need to head on over to that butcher
down the street and he's going to chop
off your genitals and you're going to
put on high heels and you're gonna put
on a bunch of lipstick and you're going
to pretend to be a woman now if the
psychologist does that that's called
gender affirming treatment that's Health
Care in fact that's pretty much the only
thing the psychologist is allowed to do
in half of the states at plus additional
territory so in more than half of the
country
that's pretty much all the psychologist
is allowed to isn't that a little bit
weird
in both cases you've got a guy walking
in to a psychologist saying hey I'm
confused I'm suffering from confusion
some distress I'm being torn between two
things obviously he's experiencing that
distress obviously he's not secure in
his views if he were secure in his views
he wouldn't be going to the psychologist
so the psychologist is converting him to
one thing or the other
it's just if the psychologist converts
him to the view that men are men and
ought to behave like men
that's evil that's terrible that's
illegal
if the psychologist converts him to the
view that men can actually become women
and they ought to pretend to be a
caricature of a woman and and undergo
painful mutilations of their body that
is that's the good conversion
does that make sense seems kind of like
the opposite to me why is it the case
that a a man in this country
is not allowed in half the country at
least is not allowed to go into a
psychologist and if he says look I'm
experiencing sexual confusion I think
I'm a woman but I want to recognize that
I'm a man or I'm experiencing sexual
confusion I'm attracted to men but I
want to try to mitigate some of those
impulses and and be able to live a life
that is chaste and does not lead me to
indulge those desires why is a man not
allowed to do that in America
it's not just that the psychologist is
not allowed to practice reasonable
psychology it's that the patient is not
allowed to get that care
which ironically is gender affirm and
care when you tell a man he's a man
that's that's affirming his gender when
you tell a man to behave like a man that
is affirming his gender
and yet today we call up down and left
right and good evil and evil good
there's there's a therapist who I had on
the show years ago years and years ago
because he came out with a book Joseph
Nicolosi Jr
and I've been attacked for even talking
to this guy because it turned out he's a
conversion therapist allegedly he says
that term is ridiculous he refers to his
reintegrative therapy Joseph Nicolosi Jr
uh is just a guy who if you come to him
and you say hey Doc I'm a man but I
wanna I wanna resolve my confusion seem
more like more like a regular guy he
tries to help you through that he is
persona non grata and he's been blowing
the whistle on Sam Britain for a long
time he said Brenton claims he was in
torture therapy as a young child for
years and can't remember the therapist's
name he later claimed the therapy took
place in his 20s but even as he was
attacking therapies that don't exist he
was engaging in sadomasochism and
simulated bestiality bestiality with
young men and women
of course no one cared about his
credibility until he got caught stealing
the luggage
totally crazy and there are a lot of
swishes and Libs you even identify
themselves on the right who will say
well I oppose conversion therapy what
that doesn't mean anything
conversion therapy it's another example
of the libs
creating a brand manipulating language
to control our minds to control the way
we perceive the world
to to win the debate before the debate
even begins which is the phenomenon that
I described in my book speechless
controlling words controlling rights
number one National bestseller a great
Christmas present still plenty of time
to receive it before Christmas
don't take the there is no such thing as
conversion therapy it's not real lock
that one away with the tooth fairy okay
all there is is therapy there's
psychology
and the kind that is legal today is the
one that tells men
fake false things
and the one that's illegal today is the
one that tells man the truth does that
make sense no I don't think so
doesn't make sense at all so what's the
consequence of all this there's a video
just went around
of of a a guy at a New York City all
ages drag show not wearing any pants
wearing a thong wearing stiletto heels
jiggling around teaching a little girl
and then even a little girl who I don't
know I'd Place her age let's say around
seven or eight I can't really tell from
the picture and and in front of kids who
are much younger even than that
I have mercifully
blurred out this man's nauseating
derriere
but he's Dan it's not even as though the
guy jiggling around half naked on stage
doesn't know that the little kids are
watching he's doing it for the kids
they're in the front row and he's
looking at the girl who's dancing around
with him and teaching her how to twerk
and so now we're all going to be
outraged we're gonna be outraged
and we need to yell about this and where
can you imagine this is weird this is
bizarre
conservatives look I'm guilty of it too
we all do it we look at this bizarre
behavior we say that's bizarre that's
weird
sort of is it really bizarre in today's
day and age no it happens all the time
we cover it on the show three times a
week
it happens all the time
we can be repulsed by this we can be
nauseated by this we should not be
shocked by this we should not be
surprised this is what has been
happening four years
and this has been a phenomenon
accelerating in the culture for decades
and it is not going to stop
until we make it stop
this is not going to stop
until we
enforce laws that are already on the
books against this kind of stuff public
indecency laws obscenity laws and it's
not going to stop until we throw these
people in prison
yeah we can publicize it we can talk all
I've got right here is a microphone and
a camera so we can talk about it we can
expose it a lot of people aren't totally
aware that this is happening and they
don't even but when they hear about it
they don't even believe wait this guy's
doing what in front of kids what no
there's no way I can't believe it and
then you see it so it helps you realize
the problem is real
but it's not going to stop just because
we shine a light on it it will only stop
when we throw these people in prison
okay and a lot of conservatives they say
well we don't I don't want to do that
that's the big government that's the
naughty evil big government I've been
told that we can never use the
government to do anything because that
would that would make us no different
from the Liberals you see if I arrest
child Predators who prepares around half
naked in front of five-year-olds that
well really that'd be no different than
if I were a liberal and I arrested a
preacher wouldn't it so let's not do
that let's just complain about it now if
we complain enough then then they'll
they'll voluntarily stop doing all the
Terrible Things no they won't
they obviously won't
so what are we gonna we're doing what we
can do
okay we are exposing this stuff showing
you what a problem it is
and then the people listening to this
show
and the great Grassroots activists
around the country
you are all doing what you can do you
were showing up to school boards you're
showing up to your local government
you're writing your Congressman you're
yelling at them you're sometimes
throwing the bums out
the Republicans have to do their job
enforce the law in the cases where laws
have been repealed put new laws on the
books
throw these people in prison wield your
power pull an Elon pull an Elon sell all
the Liberals toys okay get rid of all
the Liberals toys the drag queens and
the stilettos and the and the weird
luggage and the Sam Brinton accessories
and get rid of it make an example assert
some freaking strength and fortitude and
political dominance on the occasions you
get it or when this continues to happen
you'll have no one to blame but yourself
politicians
what are we getting I have the proof of
this Joe Biden just signed this bill
into law to abolish marriage and uh the
the the law it's called the what are
they calling it the respect for Marriage
Act but what all it really does is
define marriage out of existence and Joe
Biden to celebrate this wonderful event
has invited a drag queen to the White
House
drag queen Marty G Cummings uh is is
attending the respect for marriage act
at the White House and he says to be a
non-binary drag artist invited to the
White House is something I never
imagined would happen yeah you and me
both brother grateful doesn't begin to
express the emotions that I feel
so the political order encourages this
stuff that's why it happens
and the only way that you're going to
get rid of it
to create political conditions in which
this sort of thing is unpleasant there
have always been transvestites there
have always been Unix there have always
been people who are sexually depraved
and Confused their behavior for most of
our history has been relegated to back
alleys
to the Shadows to the fringes which is
where this sort of thing belongs if
because it is a Fallen World We are
never going to get rid of perverts uh
desire to take off half their clothing
and jiggle their derriere in front of
five-year-olds you're actually not going
to just get rid of that so what can you
do about it the only thing you can do is
relegate that to the Shadows create the
political conditions in which that sort
of thing is considered very very
shameful and not elevated to the status
of a White House presidential signing
well we can fight back we actually can
you are seeing this from the North
Carolina State Treasurer is fighting
back this would be uh Dale Falwell uh
who is in his role as state treasure is
calling for the resignation of the CEO
of BlackRock
you've seen this move and we've talked
about it on the show of State treasurers
wielding their State Pension funds their
their large assets to fight back against
the woke ESG asset managers so BlackRock
State Street Vanguard because the way
that the system works is you've got
these political activists put pressure
on the asset managers
the asset managers wield their political
power to force the companies that they
control to implement all sorts of crazy
policies
the one I keep coming back to is Cracker
Barrel selling vegan sausage
vegetarian impossible whatever sausage
no human being ever in history
who has walked into Cracker Barrel has
wanted vegetarian sausage
didn't matter the asset managers wanted
that and so that's what they get
that is 100 what they are going to get
and so uh what what the state treasurer
is called for is not even just divesting
from BlackRock he's called for the CEO
good I love it let's do it baby let's do
it let's let's go in there let's
pressure these companies I don't want to
hear about the free Marketplace of ideas
and how we can never interfere in the
economy the marketplace rules are set by
political actors that's how our system
is set up and it is a wonderful
wonderful thing when we the people can
exercise the little bit of political
power that we still have through our
elected representatives to bring these
people back to
order okay to bring these people to heal
I love free markets I don't want to
sound like I'm just some command and
control knuckle dragging dictator but
they've got to be in their proper place
and when when we get into this sort of
situation it looks a lot more like the
tail is wagging the dog and it's
extremely disordered and it's
disrespectful of the people speaking of
disrespect of the people
have you seen the most popular seed from
the Harry and Megan documentary
how to explain that you bow to your
grandmother
and that you will need to curse you
especially to an American like that's
weird now I'm starting to realize this
is a big deal I mean Americans will
understand this we have Medieval Times
dinner and tournament it was like that
like I couldn't see it as though I was
like
[Music]
laughs
pleasure to meet you your majesty
like was that okay
it was so intense
I was so stupid oh yeah I had to bow
down to my husband's dumb Grandma you
know her just dumb stupid Grandma one of
the most dignified and beloved people on
Earth yeah wasn't that wasn't that right
hubby what a dumb thing we did huh he's
just sitting there like you'd see
oh man my life why did I do this I'm so
uh I could have had a good future but
then
it's so disrespectful
what Megan Markle is doing here
it's disrespectful obviously to the
light Queen it's disrespectful to her
husband it's disrespectful to the people
of the United Kingdom because she is
insulting their Sovereign and their
entire political order
and why is she doing that I don't even
think she's doing it intentionally I
don't think she's setting out to insult
the people of the UK she's doing it
because she doesn't believe that
anything matters other than
her individualism
her individual expression why do I have
to engage in this formal behavior that
is prescribed by tradition in the word I
just come on this is so dumb and stupid
I just want to do whatever I want to do
we fall into that error too
we fall into that error a little bit too
in America the left and the right the
left obviously all they care about is
people doing whatever they want at least
when it comes to sex when it comes to
drugs when it comes to the social issues
but the right to the right says
individuals should be able to do
whatever the hell they want
some people on the right think that
that's true of sex and drugs but
especially when it comes to the economy
well you know
if Larry Fink over there a BlackRock
wants to
force all of the companies under his
under his control to pursue the radical
left-wing ESG agenda well that's his
right build your own BlackRock
if he wants to completely upend our
political order and if a handful of
people forget about just the asset
managers Silicon Valley if Facebook and
Twitter and Google want to completely
rewrite how the Public Square works in
the United States or self-governing
Republic
well that just build your own
Communications
build your own Public Square build your
own
handful of companies that control 90 of
the flow of information around our
country
no how about how about I just wield the
government that I have maybe a little
bit of control in
to stop you from doing that
maybe we recognize as Edmund Burke
recognized that there is a higher form
of freedom than individual freedom when
Edmund Burke writes in the most famous
passage in Reflections on the revolution
in France
that
there is such a thing as the spirit of
an exalted Freedom that keeps alive even
in that remains alive even in servitude
itself
and this is one of the Great
Revelations of Christianity
is that
there is a a higher form of freedom than
just pursuing your appetites whenever
you want that you can actually be the
freest man in the world even when you're
being tortured even when you're even
when you're in undergoing conversion
therapy that doesn't really exist even
even when you are in servitude even when
you are in prison
there's a higher form of freedom
in the cultivation of one's rational
will and the suppression of one's basest
instincts in the pursuit of something
higher and good and true and and we can
express that exalted freedom in another
way not just through our spiritual lives
but in political life
that to have a good flourishing Society
is a a much higher sort of freedom
even if it means in order to have a
Floridian singing Society we need to
we need to suppress some of our base
desires we need to not steal we need to
not murder people we need to not rape
people we need to not cheat people we
need not to fraud people we need to rein
in some of the stuff we want to do in
order to have a good flourishing Society
but anybody if you asked anybody okay
would you rather live in
the United States
well today I don't know people are
probably on the fence about that but
would you even today would you rather
live in the United States where you're
gonna have to play by some rules and
you're gonna have to suppress some of
the things you want to do or would you
rather live in Somalia where there are
no rules and there is no government you
can do whatever you want
until the Pirates show up and kill your
family and take your stuff
nobody would choose Somalia over the
United States because that higher
expression of political freedom
even at the cost of individual freedom
is far far greater
and so we need to we need to exercise
that exalted Freedom more you're seeing
it happen Maryland even Maryland where
the Republican Governor there's a big
squish named Larry Hogan even he is
flexing that political Freedom right now
and he is Banning state government
devices
uh from having tick tock on them
why because Tick Tock is owned by the
Chinese and it gives the Chinese
Communist party all sorts of data that
we don't want and the app is just pure
poison right I mean the app is so much
more addictive than any of the social
media platforms there was a study some
some time ago that showed that the
average Twitter user is on Twitter the
media and Twitter user is on Twitter for
anywhere from two to four minutes per
day
maybe six minutes you're a heavy user
Tick Tock people are on Tick Tock for 50
minutes plus per day it's not even close
and what are they consuming on Tick Tock
just a bunch of mind-numbing nonsense
so Larry Hogan banded for government
employees on government devices because
of the security concerns
we could go further I'm all for just
Banning Tick Tock just ban it
and especially ban it because they have
been suppressing my account for many
months now so
daily wire runs an account for me for
tick tock I'm not exactly scrolling on
Tick Tock because I'm not a 15 year old
girl but but daily wire runs an account
for me and they've suppressed it like
intensely suppressed it when I put out
that video of the uh Thanksgiving crazy
conservative Uncle a couple days before
Thanksgiving
on Instagram it did about seven million
views on Facebook it did probably
upwards of a million views Twitter
probably upwards of a million views and
then Tick Tock about 7 000 views on my
account
but then other people ripped off the
video and uploaded it they did millions
of views on tick tock
so it's also
that just Sherman she doesn't like me
very much I guess that Tick Tock is
suppressing me and so I'm all for let's
just ban Tick Tock but even if I didn't
have a personal interest in it
it's it's not good for people does
anyone really think that it's good to be
to have 12 year olds scrolling Tick Tock
all day long no of course not
in the olden days we would just suppress
that we would use the law to suppress
that sort of a thing but now
the left doesn't want us to because they
want to spread degeneracy and decadence
around the culture and the right doesn't
either because we've bought this this
crazy idea of of some unridled right to
individual liberty or something like
that which is not Liberty at all it's
really nothing more than license
so good even Utah right now the
Republican Governor there Spencer Cox
has banned Tick Tock from State devices
I say this is not just not an overstep
of the government not just not
a a an expression of the tyrannical
State now what I say is it's a good
start I say we need to go much much
further now it's time to kick
woke companies out of your man's
bathroom Okay Jeremy's razors is a
premium Men's Grooming company that's
shockingly does not hate men they've got
a full range of men's Staples including
a Precision 5 razor with a flip back
trimmer tea tree and argon oil shampoo
and conditioner I was just using that
this morning it's fabulous that's how I
got this quaff today body sub facial
moisturizer lots more it's got the whole
routine covered
air body beard skin care products
they're made in the USA it's a win-win
you love that he's cleaning up without
parabens or sulfates he's going to love
supporting a company that does not hate
his guts Jeremy's razors is 100 woke
free and now you get 30 off his gift
bundle when you order by December 15th
switch your man over to Jeremy's razors
to kick woke out of his bathroom go to
dailywire.com Knowles today also be sure
to get your mailbag questions in
you know how to how to do it right you
head on over to dailywire.com
click on the show Pages click the
Michael Knowles show you obviously have
to be a member you submit questions to
the mailbag
when you do that it's going to open up
an email and you just attach an audio
file you can record it on your phone you
can record it on your computer please
keep it to a minute or less I don't need
the story of your life okay I won't be
able to play it on the air but submit
that voicemail bag
to our mail bag and we'll be able to
read them on Friday
speaking of corruption at social media
sites
the Twitter files keep on coming not a
huge update today one thing really
really tickled me though
the Twitter employees as they were
debating whether or not to kick Trump
off Twitter you know the duly elected
sitting president
they compared him to a certain
historical figure
do you know which one
I'll give you one I'll give you one
guess which historical figure
did you guessed it right they called him
Hitler
the members of the team that's according
to one of the internal memos said just
to update you blank I spoke to blank
just now so they're censoring some of
the names
they understand our assessment of this
individual tweet but they now view him
as the leader of a terrorist group
responsible for violence slash deaths
comparable to Christ Church shooter or
Hitler
on that basis and on the totality of his
tweets he should be de-platformed
that
so I'm yes they called Trump Hitler
everyone called Trump Hitler on the left
for years and years and years but
even let's say you take the very worst
that happened on January 6th January 6th
the worst Insurrection ever even though
nobody's been charged with Insurrection
and well they killed those police
officers no they actually didn't they
didn't kill any police officers and well
but people died right the person who
died was Ashley babichi was shot by a
trigger happy cop she was a trump
supporter actually
Trump supporters didn't didn't kill
people
to say that
he's equivalent to the Christ Church
shooter or Hitler it seems somewhat
offensive to me
seems offense everyone's getting angry
at what Kanye is saying that seems that
seems pretty offensive too don't you say
it seems to be making light of Hitler
and all of his atrocities too wouldn't
you say
no of course people who compare every
political story to World War II are not
to be taken seriously
because those sort of people don't know
anything about history their only
historical frame of reference is World
War II
and because they don't know about
history they probably don't know much
about World War II either but
those people don't need to listen to
them
but but furthermore
why do they do it
they do it because by comparing us to
Hitler they can justify any actions that
they take against us and the reason for
this is
that
Hitler and the Nazis are not just people
who did things in history in the in the
popular perception Hitler is the devil
the Nazis are demons they're not human
beings they're they're the devil and
demons in fact they're worse than the
devil and the demons because the the
people who obsessively compare
everything to Hitler
probably don't believe in the devil
they're probably atheists they probably
don't believe in demons
Hitler
was for them not just a very very very
bad man but the absolute incarnation of
evil worse than the devil in that Hitler
was incarnate Hitler had a body the
devil and the demons are just Spirits
they're just demons but but the devil is
is a body I've made this point
when we were covering the Kanye story
over the past couple of weeks that Kanye
for so much of his career has just tried
to transgress taboos it goes up to the
most popular musician in the world
Taylor Swift and takes her statue on
stage or he says slavery is a choice
or he puts on the Maga hat at the time
was extremely transgressive
and he comes out and he says I I really
like Hitler
which is the most subversive thing
the most taboo thing you can possibly
say
there is nothing further and this is
more proof of that
when they compare us to Hitler and or
Nazis we laugh it off we say that's so
stupid you know you clearly don't know
anything about Hitler or Nazis you're
you're clearly don't know what Trump is
actually doing but we should take it a
little bit more seriously because what
what this that actually means when they
say you are like Hitler is
there is nothing that we would not be
justified in doing to you
we would we would we would kill Baby
Hitler they would kill baby us they
would kill a lot of babies that's what
they do they would do
absolutely anything
there are different tracks of Justice we
know this in the United States
if you burn down the country for eight
months along with BLM you'll get a slap
on the wrist probably won't even have
any charges filed against you
if you walk into the capital rotunda and
you dance around a little bit in a horn
hat and maybe crack a chorus light they
will throw the book at you they'll put
you in solitary confinement
you're seeing this right now in a
different way with Pete bootage who
probably is my least favorite of the
Biden appointees even more than the
crazy nuclear energy guy even more than
all of the the rest of this really
shadowy cast of characters because
Buddha judge is so glib he's just so uh
he's just that guy who went to Harvard
and worked at McKinsey and then kind of
talked soon I was like hey hey guys come
on I'm just I'm just a reasonable one
okay Bridges and roads are really really
racist guys and I'll see you in about
six months I've got to go take off some
maternity leave so that I can go
breastfeed my child
but it's totally reasonable because I
want people to judge and I'm just I'm
just a really nice guy actually but I
just I think half the country is evil
and terrible
and bigoted huh
so he just drives me crazy because he's
so glib and so disingenuous but Pete
butterjudge
he does like the Finer Things in life
okay he likes taking four to six months
off as a vacation right after he starts
his job
he likes flying around on private jets
it turns out new new report shows
that uh Pete butterjudge has taken
private jets
at least 18 times since he was
inaugurated into office
there were commercial flights available
but he took the private jets ironic
because Pete bootage Edge
talks about how he cares about the
environment he makes climate change a
big part of his political platform
obviously he doesn't really care all
that much about the environment his
private jets spews so much more
pollution into the air than commercial
air travel does but it's also ironic
because Pete butterjudge is the
Secretary of Transportation
so it's his job to make sure that
transportation is run effectively in the
United States so of any political
appointee I'm not begrudging political
appointees they're private jets
sometimes people at the very top layers
of government really
ought to take a private jet because it's
the most efficient way to get to a place
and important work has to be done but
when you're talking about the Secretary
of Transportation it's a pretty bad look
because your job is to run all the
non-private jet modes of transportation
that we are all supposed to rely on and
if Pete's argument here is well you
can't expect me to take a commercial air
travel that sucks it's a terrible
experience and very often the the
flights will be delayed or canceled and
and I'll have to sit in those tiny
little seats next to disgusting uh
members of the hoi polloi you just can't
expect me to do that so I'm going to
take my private jets then then that's a
really bad look it shows that you're
sort of failing at your job
just a reminder
Donald Trump's Secretary of Health and
Human Services lost his job for this
Donald Trump's HHS secretary Tom Price
took 25 private jets
so a little bit more than Buddha judge
but not a lot 18 versus 25 and Pia to
resign in disgrace bipartisan
investigations everybody agreed on this
Pete booty judge nothing will happen to
him because of
this we all know it
they just get away with it and so what
what should we do about this
but we can either whine and scream and
cry get blue in the face or I would just
recommend next time that there's a Tom
Price who's taking some private jets and
is targeted with a mostly contrived
political attack obviously we should
root out corruption in a red party but
the Tom Price attack was pretty
contrived
a lot of a lot of top politicos take
private jets maybe Tom over did it a
little bit but it was mostly just a way
to attack the Trump Administration next
time that happens
Let It Go
there is no need to
go after him like that okay no need to
do that sort of thing speaking of
flying high and political power players
Ron DeSantis is having a very good year
I meant to get to this last week
didn't have time but Juan Williams or
he's the Democrat on Fox News Juan
Williams has just come out with his
annual column on the most important
Power Player politician in the country
he says it's DeSantis
he says DeSantis is 2022's most
important politician unfortunately he's
not my cup of tea in fact he scares me
but it is time for me to hand out my
year-end award for the top political
player in the United States these days
there needs to be one top prize and it
goes to Ron DeSantis very very difficult
to disagree with that whether you are
the most Ardent Trump supporter in the
world whether you totally hate Donald
Trump whether you I don't know you're a
Tim Scott or a Nikki Haley stand or
something like that
the rise that Ron DeSantis has had
from an obscure Congressman back bench
or didn't really do very much
in the house it's hard to do really
anything that has a representatives to
the most prominent effective
conservative governor in America has
been absolutely astounding
and if you're if you're Donald Trump if
you're so if you're anyone else who
wants to run for president that is a big
big deal okay and so you're seeing the
political ground shifting right now even
though Democrats did much better in the
midterms than you you necessarily would
have expected you can see things aren't
looking great for the Democrats that's
why Kirsten Cinema had to leave the
Democrat Party
you're seeing the exposure of the
Twitter files and the collaboration
between the big Tech platforms and the
Democrat Party you're seeing things
shaking so as we head now into 2023
which will just become the 2024
presidential race you're seeing the
political roundshifting things are are
not settled
what the Republicans believe is not
settled what the governing agenda will
be how and if they will wield power
those are the fights that are happening
right now we can all learn a lesson we
can learn a lesson from those Democrats
who will power very effectively we can
learn a lesson from Elon Musk
we can see if we can summon the courage
to do it ourselves the rest of the show
continues now you do not want to miss it
if you're not a member click the link in
the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]